non vraiment je vais pas vous mentir le
jour le matin où j'ai balancé ses vidéos
c'est vrai que j'avais une boule au
ventre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là vous êtes vous arrivé
pile de la réunion lé en fait oui je
sors de l'avion là d'accord alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec ce photographe
ben je pensais arriver dans un studio
photo
je trouve que je me retrouve enfermé
chez un mec que je ne connais pas il a
fermé sa porte à clé bon ben
alors donc je vous dis j'ai lu ça dans
wii vont ils vous dit je vais te demandé
d'écarter les jambes oui au bout d'un
moment ça n'a pas été tout de suite au
début c'était pas du tout ce genre de
photos qu'on devait faire parce que
savoir que c'est un photographe qui
signait je pense que je ne sais pas à
l'heure actuelle mais signé des éditos
de son nom je dirais travail et une
grande agence de mannequins avec autant
là je vais te demander des quartiers
jambes de fixer l'objectif en prenant un
air de ac ça
donc quand vous sentez à ce moment là
quand vous sortez de votre mac
je vais à dire aussi que quand j'ai vu
effectivement les photos dans le
magazine ce que les gens ne savent pas
c'est que je ne me rappelle pas m'être
retrouvé complètement donc ça a été
terriblement choquant pour moi c'est à
dire je ne me rappelle pas de du
basculement quand je me suis retrouvé le
souci moi ce qui me dérange c'est que
vous dites que vous avez eu une amnésie
donc du coup il ya même plus d'histoire
au delà de l'amnésie moi j'ai vu ces
photos pour les besoins de l'émission à
moi je connaissais pas ces photos c'est
même pas des photos sexy parce que moi
des photos sexy j'en ai fait en
sous-vêtements j'en ai fait là c'est des
photos pornographiques je vais me dire
que même des photos pornographiques sont
plus propres que ce que vous avez alors
non je vous ai des photos ou oui je n'ai
de fond des phares et et le cracher
dessus elle dit vous écarter les cuisses
soin ses skis et puisque vous avez les
cuisses écartées je dirais même plus on
voit plus vos doigts parce que vaudois
sont à l'intérieur de vous je vais vous
des choses que vous êtes en train de
dire vous rendez compte je n'ai jamais
ça il faut que les jeunes filles qui
nous écoutent qui ont vécu ce genre de
choses robecq facile de bain les navets
les îles moi je vais vous vous rendez
beaucoup de motos discours face à tous
ces jeunes filles syndiqués ou non avec
une équipe formée samedi dans le doubs
l'achat il m'est arrivé
même débat ce n'est pas le même davies
avait franchement demander où le vélo
pour nous être une erreur de jeunesse
arnaud grasset ce n'est pas une erreur
c'est bon
plus d'une femme dix neuf ans de
n'importe quel âge à bil'in pas que ce
soit ma meilleure amie qui ai fait ça
j'aimerais pas que ce soit ma cousine et
moi sommes amers j'aimerais pas que
j'ai juste avant noël c'est une erreur
de jeunesse et aujourd'hui on dit j'ai
eu un blackout ce qu'on fait
généralement une fois qu'on a été sous
et on dit j'ai fait de la merde mais en
fait j'ai fait un black out j'aimerais
bien plus si c'est exactement juste
voilà mais il faut pas oublier que ces
photos quand on les voit sortis du
contexte et des photos effectivement
très salée si vous êtes victime vous est
visé c'est par lui que 19 ans qui font
des photos comme ça pour se prouver des
choses et ça non plus c'est pas bien
pouliot a parents d'une fille mais je
trouve extrêmement avec kelly en fait le
débat c'est parce que c'est bien ou pas
bien de faire des photos sexy pas sexy
pornographiques pas pornographique elle
est en train de dire qu'elle est tombée
sur un photographe vers eux que ces
photos en plus ont été faits dans un
contexte privé et qu'elles ont été
extorqués ils se retrouvent publiées à
la une d'un magazine complet sont
d'accord c'est dégueulasse
et privés ce alors je remets pas en
cause si vous êtes fait mis enfin voila
si vous êtes fait drogués c'est une
chose moi je parle juste de la qualité
de photo une photo comme ça mène à mon
copain j'en vois pas une fouille tout le
monde
en effet alors que les candidats ont
toujours dû se débrouiller par eux-mêmes
pour se nourrir j'ai une force ni qu'on
me levés hier soir denis brogniart a
révélé que témoin candidats de koh lanta
la légende avait triché en bénéficions d
d'extérieur vous avez demandé à des
pêcheurs qui passaient au large de la
nourriture des révélations que
l'aventurier a confirmé avant de
présenter ses excuses
même moi je ne comprends pas comment
j'ai pu franchir ce cette ligne sont
limitées l'histoire chronologiquement on
entend des bruissements dans les retours
de noeux des micros c'est à dire on
capte voilà et on entend des trucs en
lien avec des histoires de papaye bon et
puis partage pas pareil on comprend pas
très bien et en écoutant un peu plus on
se dit qu'il ya quelque chose et à ce
moment là julien magne quel producteur
du programme et qui étaient sur place va
voir les aventuriers et là en posant des
questions theora va immédiatement avoué
que
en effet il a triché
c'est quand même important c'est là une
première dans koh lanta
donc il faut se rappeler qu'on est en
polynésie qui à 12 heures de décalage ce
et c'est là où habite et où il ya la
famille tous oui alors comme vous le
savez tes bras et polynésiens on était
d'ailleurs sur des îles qu'il connaît
bien il en a déjà parlé un certain et
raiatea et on avait fait justement et
ultra attention parce qu'on savait qu'il
pouvait y avoir un risque on lui avait
parlé avant l'émission on n'avait fait
attention de prendre par exemple les
pilotes des bateaux que ça ne soit pas
des pilotes de l'île de pâques ils
connaissent teo aloha etc qui est pas
bien ce qui a posé problème c'est que
c'est christelle une candidate dont qui
a découvert les papayes ça d'ailleurs
vous avez les images c'est que ce serait
bien de les montrer un jour je sais que
la scène a été filmée bon elle découvre
salle pète les plombs il regarda on en
rappelle les images de la dh de papa et
oui ça c'est vrai à ce moment-là
découvre tout elle pète les plombs et en
enquêtant vous apercevez quand même que
vraiment et où ira c'est pas isolé il y
avait beaucoup de fois où il a fait
appel selon mes infos un piroguier pour
amener des choses sur l'île beaucoup de
légumes etc et vous savez très bien
qu'il ya deux aventuriers emblématiques
on peut citer les noms je pense parce
que ils ont mangé ses seins mais claude
ils ont mangé ils ont partagé on m'a
donné d'autres non mais je suis sûr
c'est quand même bizarre qu'on ne les
veut pas entendre ça nous coûte cyril
là c'est bizarre et b alors j'ai
beaucoup d'autre part à manger la goûter
c'est quand même bizarre que voulaient
les chais contient alors déjà vous
affirmer des choses ag oui
il ya eu énormément de rumeurs et c'est
justement parce que y avait une
certitude des rumeurs et que nous on a
pris la décision en effet de sanctionner
que celui qui l'organisé
pourtant jamais dit à leurs besoins et à
leurs alliés ok pote alexia alexia les
la soir déjà elle aurait pu ne pas venir
elle vient venait expliquer tous les
salaires est l'aîné droite dans ses
bottes alexia voilà est-ce que vous avez
songé à soumettre le candidat aux autres
hôtels espérant détecteur de mensonge
mais
ne s'empire ou pas c'est pas son nom
alors oui mais voilà non alors il ya une
spécificité sur cette saison c'est et
toi tu l'a découvert c'est qu'il y avait
l'île des bannis oui donc au moment où
on a terminé avec les chroniqueurs à
l'engagement ou l'internât rochelle et
dans l'île des bannières
édition n'avait fait une sorte de
consciencieux ont révélé un élément qui
était un élément secret de mécanique
c'est que en fin de compte jusqu'à la
fin vous avez l'île des bannis donc
c'était pas possible
c'est le cas de sarah prix doux qui a
pris la parole sur son compte ce match
est il ya quelques jours pour révéler
qu'il était victime de chantage à la
sextape une vidéo intime que menace de
divulguer un de ses ex la personne ma
fille mais j'avais demandé que soit
supprimée mais pour stopper cet
engrenage sahara était ma ligne a fait
un pied de nez à l'homme en question en
publions elle même la vie oh c'est ouais
c'est jeu partie basse et le bat r je
rencontre quelqu'un et voilà comme dans
toute relation ou toute personne qui
rencontre quelqu'un bat ont fait
quelques vidéos on rigole sur le coup et
au final bas canton benhaim on a fait
beaucoup moins
avec des tumeurs
et au final quand je rentre chez moi et
que huit mois plus tard on en voit la
vidéo en me disant petit souvenir de
nous
cinquante casse a dit ok cool pourquoi
donc ça veut dire ce petit souvenir de
nous il en voyez vous les 50000 euros
pour ne pas diffuser la vidéo c'est
exactement ça a commencé de l'aca a
commencé à deux on fait comment moi que
je sais c'est galère dans ma vie dit
et puis voilà et je pense que ta famille
sera pas contente en fait je me suis dit
mais en fait non j'ai pas envie de
passer au téléphone avec untel untel est
en fait c'est pas les enchères mon corps
n'est pas les enchères cette vidéo n'est
pas les enchères en fait est arrivé à un
moment donné je me suis posée j'ai
contacté mais de grand frère jared
j'écoute il s'est passé ça ça ça ça à
telle période j'ai appelé ma mère judy
écoute ya un truc qui va sortir c'est
moi qui va le faire parce qu'en fait il
y en a assez arrive à un moment donné où
est-ce que vous en aviez marre du
chantage ou a dit je vais sortir moi
même la vidéo terminée exactement c'est
voilà maintenant tu veux me faire peur
avec ça bahia personnes qui me fait peur
et je la balance moi même en fait ouais
c'est ça un moment vous avez hésité à
lui donner les 50000 euros pas du tout
j'avais pas du tout je vais et je vais
pas vous mentir je préfère me mettre
dans le mal moi que donner quelque chose
à quelqu'un parce qu'en vrai
qu'elle mérite en fait ça veut dire
qu'elle aura gagné tout ce que en fait
tout ce qu'elle est a voulu à leur a
gagné je donne 50 mais le roi elle à
l'envoi la vidéo à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est comment avec 10 personnes derrière
nom paraît que vous avez pensé au pire à
ce moment là ouais ouais vraiment mais
vraiment vous êtes dit ma vie est foutue
vraiment s'est passé mais c'est ma vie
est foutue parce que c'est uci on va pas
se mentir et maintenant moi je suis on
va pas tu leur but on va parler français
je suis une rebelle chez nous c'est un
truc de ouf je vous avais plein coeur
chantage ou pas du tout non j'ai fait ma
justice moi-même sur les réseaux parce
que comme comme comme je l'expliquais
souvent bartholin c'est mozart mais
aussi moins déranger une justice où il
ya un problème en fait ça veut dire non
il ya un problème pourquoi pourquoi je
vais vous expliquer parce que vous allez
porter plainte mais avant ça on m'a tuer
ma vie la vie des malades j'en ai
partout non mais
moi en fait porté par des gens d'âgés
pas mal je suis désolé en fait l'on me
fait de l'artiste c'est bien mais pour
moi moi personnellement je parle de moi
c'est trop d'eux trop il ya trop de
route avant d'arriver au point final il
ya trop de souffrance de deux temps en
fait je trouve que vous a libéré c'est
très clairement vraiment je vais pas
vous mentir le joug le matin où j'ai
balancé ses vidéos c'est vrai que
j'avais une boule au ventre moi je me
suis dit comment ça va se passer les
raisons sait tous très bien comment ils
peuvent déformer le truc détourner le
truc j'avais une boule au ventre
oui
et donc ça et de la et de la vraiment
depuis ce jour là vraiment c'est le
lendemain c'est je suis tranquille mais
les gens sont soulagés vous vous êtes
vous avez un petit fiancé un nom j'ai
une fréquentation et quand à wii sa part
tout d'abord de fréquentation
est contestée est à fréquentation à
l'adie quoi de
fréquentation au début quand elle a
voulu ça c'est dit ok dans quoi je me
lance et en fait au final non est très
contente et au final j'avais déjà parlé
de ces vidéos alors qu'on tire même pas
il ya une semaine avant ouais à la fois
comme
une semaine à une semaine avant je
parlais de ça carrément je lui ai dit tu
sais qu'on m'a déjà fait chanter oui je
te préviens je te préviens si demain il
ya un truc qui sort ou quoi que ce soit
tu es prévenu l'afrique c'est quoi
et bam très cantous
pierre merci d'être là huit mois tpe à
l'antenne alors et donc d'annoncer sa
plateforme pierrot le foot me mois après
cette sortie de l'antenne c'était aussi
qu'après la décision si l'un d'eux c'est
toi je sais qu'il avait dit qu'il y
avait toutes santé plus haut si tu te
sentais plus de faire d'antenne en fin
d'un commun accord voilà c'est ça veut
on était arrivé à un tel déferlement de
haine sur les réseaux que
c'est les raisons qui ont fait que t'as
pas repris l'antenne louis non mais pas
complètement j'ai eu huit mois plus tard
je n'ai jamais eu dans la rue une
personne qui m'a insulté jamais pas une
j'étais triste quand même parce que
denard oui je suis toujours très fine ça
tu manques oui bien sûr
7 c'est manqué ouais bah oui
c'était ma vie pendant pendant 11 ans
cette émission c'est moi ce sont
clairement les réseaux sociaux qui ont
eu raison et de mon travail à canal et
des contrats publicitaires que j'avais
appelé aucun contrat là des gens qui
t'ont soutenu
anonymement plein plein et je leur fais
partie
cette pnj l'ont fait partie
mais
je n'ai jamais demandé à personne de me
soutenir je vais le dire parce qu'ils
auraient été pris dans la tourmente
parce que s'il n'y avait pas eu les
réseaux sociaux est-ce que vous aurez
pris la même décision que vous avez pris
aujourd'hui d'arrêter de
lui les réseaux sociaux
j'aurais pas perdu mes contrats
se rendent compte qu al le jeu lun
fameux jeu de foot dont je faisais la
voix depuis cinq ans ma virée sur
twitter
pierre ménès ne fera plus la voix du jeu
si vous voulez plus entendre la voix de
pierre ménès vous pouvez mettre le jeu
dans une autre langue c'est ok et j'ai
reçu le courrier chez moi cinq jours
plus tard est ce que vous vous rendez
compte de la violence du truc avec le
procès médiatique à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui devenu bien plus important
finalement quand même pas appelé tu
penses que tu vas revenir aux télés ou
pas tu as envie oui oui j'ai envie mais
là je suis très très concentré sur la
plateforme c'est une grosse pression
d'accord moi qui ai jamais vraiment
tellement la pression professionnelle
manqué toujours vécu les choses il ya
des gens qui ont dit qu'ils avaient reçu
eric zemmour pour la première qui
tombent sont tombés dessus alors ce
n'est pas la première c'est la première
personnalité politique
oui alors l'appareil déferlement de
haine je suis un nazi je suis
donc c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire quand je vais recevoir mélenchon
mois idéal gauche de lance des messages
quand tu devras jean luc mélenchon et
nigel gault si vous voulez tu vas
recevoir anne hidalgo ils vont dire que
tu es dans le btp
et pourquoi pourquoi zemmour en premier
parce que c'est le premier qui m'a dit
oui c'est vrai son téléphone je les
appelais et/ou et faire une interview
sur le foot il a dit oui j'ai proposé en
droit mais on préfère ça aux trois aux
bulls et plus ces meutres les trois opus
un porte à porte de saint-cloud ça
coûtait du parquet ni c'est plus ça
c'est ça s'est très bien passé on s'est
accroché en face je m'unis que j'étais
pas d'accord notamment quoi lorsqu'il a
parlé de benzema mais d'où j'ai pas le
droit d'interviewer des mots mais les
gens sont en bray
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]